I am a web software developer.
Are you hiring your,
can I volunteer for anything?
I could build anything.
I can automate things.
I could simply be an assistant of sorts.
Thank you for your time.
Well,
what I would like to say about that is first,
thank you Adam.
It's much appreciated and a lot of people have volunteered their time to me and
their and their,
um,
technological expertise.
And as much as I'd like to make use of it,
that simple truth of the matter is that I'm sufficiently overwhelmed by the
complexity of my life at the moment,
that it's very difficult to undertake a new collaborative project with anyone.
I mean,
generally speaking,
before all this political,
um,
what would you call it before all these political events overtook my life.
I was already scheduled probably about six months to a year out.
You know,
all my time was already eaten up.
And of course the addition of everything that's happened in the last year or two
that has occupied my time to a degree that is was,
is really somewhat unimaginable.
And so I just can't take on additional help,
which is so strange because you'd think that help is help and that it would save
time.
But you know,
it's very difficult to enter into a collaborative relationship with someone and
especially if you want to give them credit and do things properly.
So,
um,
at the moment I'm afraid that I can't entertain any such offers even though I'd
like to,
and there may come a time in the future,
especially when I'm hopefully starting to work more on this online university
project.
Um,
I've got a few projects to finish up before that to the new personality task,
which we've just about got all the bugs worked out of.
And also the high school version of the future authoring program are all,
we're all set up long before any of this happened,
so I have to clear them out before I can concentrate on a new project that I
finished a book over the last couple of years to called a 12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos,
which is now available by the way,
if you're interested on Amazon for preorder.
Um,
and so anyways,
this is my roundabout way of saying thank you very much,
but I can't accept more help at the moment because my time is too restricted to
make proper use of it.
So.